- Hey guys, Dr. Berg here.
In this video we're gonna
talk about how much fat
you need to consume on a
ketogenic diet per meal.
There's a lot of theories out there
but I have an unfair advantage
because I have a lot of people
I can practice on in my clinic
to see what works and what doesn't work.
I'm gonna show you what works.
Couple things that people bring up
all the time is, is a ketogenic diet,
which means you're eating more fat,
is that dangerous for your heart?
The answer is no, it's not, in fact
it's not the fat that plugs up
your arteries, it's the sugar.
There's tons and tons of studies,
I'll put some links below, on this fact.
Ketogenic diets are not dangerous
if you do them correctly.
Second question that people say
or they've heard, they say, "Well the more
"fat that you eat, the more
fat you're gonna burn."
That's another myth because you could be
burning the dietary fat
and not your own fat.
Now the whole concept of the ketogenic
is that you're having very low carbs,
moderate protein, higher fat.
What I found is we want zero sugar,
unlimited vegetables, in fact we need
more vegetables because if you do this,
ketones are acidic and the ketones
can potentially raise your pH and you can
end up with either gout, it's a type
of arthritis, or kidney stones.
So the way to prevent that is to consume
a lot of vegetables and also lemon.
Lemon actually prevents kidney stones.
The other key is that don't
consume sugar with fat.
Why?
Because it will increase
insulin even more.
So we don't want to add the sugar
to this eating plan at all.
The other point is you
want to do this gradually.
If you're increasing fats too quickly
it's gonna overwhelm the gallbladder
and you're gonna have right shoulder pain,
and bloating, things like that.
That's why I recommend that if you're
gonna do this, highly recommend the
gallbladder formula,
because that gives you
the enzymes and the bile to help
handle this fat in the transition.
Number two, or number three is that
it does take time to adapt
your body to fat burning.
All the cells must change
their enzyme structure,
their machinery, to handle
this new fuel source,
because we're limited in the glucose
and we're increasing the
fat, and it does take
sometimes between two, three, four, five,
even six weeks to make this transition.
In the process we're gonna do this
nice and gradually so your body can go
right into it and you'll fell really good.
Now let's talk about how much
fat that you really need.
These are lists of fats that you can
potentially consume, and by the way,
I have a link that I'm creating below
so you can download this chart,
which actually is right
here.
This one right here.
So basically this is
kind of a short version.
Heavy cream.
One tablespoon is five grams of fat, okay,
so an average person, and this is
very general, needs
between 20 and 40 grams
of fat per meal on a ketogenic diet.
So this is, 40 would be the high scale,
someone really large, has
been doing it a while,
20 is someone smaller and
they're just starting out.
We're gonna calculate this kind of like
mid-range at 30 grams just
to give you an average.
So heavy cream, and you
could make whipping cream,
I have a video on that, you can make
all sorts of things with heavy cream.
Five grams, you wold do
six tablespoons per meal,
like you were gonna have that right after
the meal as your fat.
The fat's gonna allow you to go longer
so you're not as hungry, and it's not
gonna increase insulin,
is exactly what we want.
And you may only be doing two meals,
so if you're concerned about calories,
which I actually did add calories to this,
do two meals, especially
if you're not working out.
I mean, you'll find that at once you adapt
you can burn your body
fat as a fuel source
and you can go a long period of time
without having to worry about it.
Now egg is five grams of fat.
Now realize that these, there might be
more than five grams for the egg
but we're talking five grams of fat,
so one egg is five grams, so you'd
need three to four eggs per meal.
I do four eggs in the morning.
Sometimes people do two or three,
that's totally fine
because you don't have to,
you can combine these in certain ways.
So now let's get to the beef.
We got three ounces is 16 grams
so about, you know, three
to six ounces of beef.
So what I want to show
you is kind of an example
of this beef that's frozen right here.
This is some beef that's 85% lean.
I do not buy the 90% lean.
I like the 80% but it's hard to find it.
I like this thing to be more fat,
but this is the type I have
which is grass fed organic beef.
And just so you know, I do the
pasture raised organic eggs.
That's the type of eggs
that you need to consume.
So then we get coconut oil, right?
One tablespoon is 14 grams so we're
just gonna double that
and have two tablespoons.
Now you can put that on your vegetables,
you can make little
treats, there's all sorts
of recipes you can make, but that's the
type of, amount of fat that
you would need per meal.
Brie cheese, three ounces, 28 grams.
So you would just do three ounces,
so I'll show you, brie
cheese is very high in fat
and I actually took this and I drew
these little lines here to show you
what three ounces is
just to give you an idea.
It's a little slice of this.
This is like four three ounce sections.
This is 12 ounces of cheese and
one of these for a meal would give you
enough fat, but this also has the protein,
so you could kill two
birds with one stone.
And I do a lot of cheese.
Another idea, here's some
other cheese right here.
This is a German cheese.
Just less than half of
this is three ounces.
So that gives you an idea.
It's kind of like a
little bit bigger than a,
it's kinda like a, yeah, it's not a
card deck but it's a little bigger
than the palm of your
hand, but half of this
would be three ounces, okay,
just to give you an idea.
Almond butter, one tablespoon is 10 grams
so that would be three tablespoons
of almond butter that you would consume.
You can do that right after a meal.
That would be your fat.
Olive oil with one tablespoon, 14 grams,
so two tablespoons of olive oil.
That's really easy just to put
on your salad, boom, you're done.
Of course some of it's gonna end up
in the bottom, so maybe you want
to add another one, but that would
give you about 30 grams of fat.
Pecans, so 10 pecans is 20 grams,
so if you do 15 pecans, right,
at the end of the meal, or maybe
macadamia nuts, that
would give you enough fat.
Ice cream, now you're
saying, wait a second,
ice cream, can I have ice cream?
There are certain ice
creams that have no sugar.
In fact I'll show you the
one that I have right here.
So I put a chocolate brownie
on here, that's a recipe
that we have in some of the videos,
and ice cream, and you can basically
make this ice cream or
get it from the store,
and it has no sugar, and that one cup
would give you 22 grams of fat.
Now I personally, this is an ice cream
that I am developing right now.
I'm having my own line of ice cream.
Now I'm experimenting right now
and it's not perfected,
I'm in the R and D stage.
In fact a couple days ago I had
all my staff consume this much ice cream,
so I gave them a
container, 'cause I wanted
to see what would happen, right?
Half of the group had
some digestive bloating.
It was temporary but still, it's not
perfected yet so we're
gonna be perfecting this.
I have to go back to
R and D and figure out
how I'm gonna fix that,
because the last thing
I want to do is have you get it and
have you bloating and call me up and say,
"Dr. Berg, gas me out."
I don't want to go there.
So the ice cream is made with a
high quality fat, no sugar, but we
have to figure out the
soluble fibers in there
so we're working on that right now.
But that will be down the road.
Some people want to
know when it's gonna be.
I don't know.
I'm gonna have it done
when I perfect it, okay?
So this will give you an idea,
if you download the chart below it will
give you an idea of how much fat
that you really need, so go ahead and
apply this and go ahead and write your
comments below, and I
hope this helped you.
I'll see you in the next video.
Hey guys, thank you so much for watching.
I really appreciate it.
Please click the share button below
and I will see you in the next video.